hello and welcome to introduction to
large language models my name is John
Ewald and I'm a training developer here
at Google Cloud
in this course you learn to Define large
language models or llms describe llm use
cases explain prompt tuning and describe
Google's gen AI development tools
large language models or llms are a
subset of deep learning to find out more
about deep learning see our introduction
to generative AI course video
llms and generative AI intersect and
they are both a part of deep learning
another area of AI you may be hearing a
lot about is generative AI
this is a type of artificial
intelligence that can produce new
content including text images audio and
synthetic data
so what are large language models
large language models refer to large
general purpose language models that can
be pre-trained and then fine-tuned for
specific purposes
what do pre-trained and fine-tuned mean
imagine training a dog
often you train your dog basic commands
such as sit come down and stay
these commands are normally sufficient
for everyday life and help your dog
become a good canine citizen
however if you need a special service
dog such as a police dog a guide dog or
a hunting dog you add special trainings
the similar idea applies to large
language models
these models are trained for general
purposes to solve common language
problems such as text classification
question answering document
summarization and text generation across
Industries
the models can then be tailored to solve
specific problems in different fields
such as Retail Finance and entertainment
using a relatively small size of field
data sets
let's further break down the concept
into three major features of large
language models
large indicates two meetings first is
the enormous size of the training data
set sometimes at the petabyte scale
second it refers to the parameter count
in ml parameters are often called hyper
parameters
parameters are basically the memories
and the knowledge that the machine
learned from the model training
parameters Define the skill of a model
in solving a problem such as predicting
text
general purpose means that the models
are sufficient to solve common problems
two reasons lead to this idea
first is the commonality of a human
language regardless of the specific
tasks and second is the resource
restriction
only certain organizations have the
capability to train such large language
models with huge data sets and a
tremendous number of parameters how
about letting them create fundamental
language models for others to use
this leads to the last point pre-trained
and fine-tuned meaning to pre-train a
large language model for a general
purpose with a large data set and then
fine-tune it for specific aims with a
much smaller data set
the benefits of using large language
models are straightforward first a
single model can be used for different
tasks
this is a dream come true these large
language models that are trained with
petabytes of data and generate billions
of parameters are smart enough to solve
different tasks including language
translation sentence completion text
classification question answering and
more
second large language models require
minimal field training data when you
tailor them to solve your specific
problem
large language models obtain decent
performance even with little domain
training data in other words they can be
used for fuse shot or even zero shot
scenarios in machine learning few shot
refers to training a model with minimal
data and zero shot implies that a model
can recognize things that have not
explicitly been taught in the training
before
third the performance of large language
models is continuously growing when you
add more data and parameters
let's take Palm as an example in April
2022 Google released Palm short for
Pathways language model a 540 billion
parameter model that achieves a
state-of-the-art performance across
multiple language tasks
Palm is a dense decoder only Transformer
model it has 540 billion parameters it
leverages the new Pathways system which
has enabled Google to efficiently train
a single model across multiple TPU V4
pods pathway is a new AI architecture
that will handle many tasks at once
learn new tasks quickly and reflect a
better understanding of the world
the system enables Palm to orchestrate
distributed computation for accelerators
we previously mentioned that Palm is a
Transformer model a Transformer model
consists of encoder and decoder the
encoder encodes the input sequence and
passes it to the decoder which learns
how to decode the representations for a
relevant task
we've come a long way from traditional
programming to neural networks to
generative models
in traditional programming we used to
have to hard code the rules for
distinguishing a cat type animal legs 4
ears 2 fur yes likes yarn catnip
in the wave of neural networks we could
give the network pictures of cats and
dogs and ask is this a cat and it would
predict a cat
in the generative wave we as users can
generate our own content whether it be
text images audio video or other
for example models like Palm or Lambda
or language model for dialogue
applications in just very very large
data from multiple sources across the
internet and build Foundation language
models we can use simply by asking a
question whether typing it into a prompt
or verbally talking into the prompt
so when you ask it what's a cat it can
give you everything it has learned about
a cat
let's compare llm development using
pre-trained models with traditional ml
development
first with llm development you don't
need to be an expert you don't need
training examples and there is no need
to train a model
all you need to do is think about prompt
design which is the process of creating
a prompt that is clear concise and
informative it is an important part of
natural language processing
in traditional machine learning you need
training examples to train a model you
also need compute time and Hardware
let's take a look at an example of a
text generation use case
question answering or QA is a subfield
of natural language processing that
deals with the task of automatically
answering questions posed in natural
language
QA systems are typically trained on a
large amount of text and code and they
are able to answer a wide range of
questions including factual definitional
and opinion based questions the key here
is that you need domain knowledge to
develop these question answering models
for example domain knowledge is required
to develop a question answering model
for customer i t support or Healthcare
or supply chain
using generative QA the model generates
free text directly based on the context
there is no need for domain knowledge
let's look at three questions given to
Bard a large language model chat bot
developed by Google AI
question one
this year's sales are one hundred
thousand dollars expenses are sixty
thousand dollars how much is net profit
Bard first shares how net profit is
calculated then performs the calculation
then Bard provides the definition of net
profit
here's another question inventory on
hand is six thousand units a new order
requires eight thousand units how many
units do I need to fill to complete the
order
again Bard answers the question by
performing the calculation
and our last example we have 1000
sensors in 10 geographic regions how
many sensors do we have on average in
each region
Bard answers the question with an
example on how to solve the problem and
some additional context
in each of our questions a desired
response was obtained this is due to
prompt design
prompt design and prompt engineering are
two closely related Concepts in natural
language processing both involve the
process of creating a prompt that is
clear concise and informative however
there are some key differences between
the two
prompt design is the process of creating
a prompt that is tailored to the
specific task that this system is being
asked to perform
for example if the system is being asked
to translate a text from English to
French The Prompt should be written in
English and should specify that the
translation should be in French
prompt engineering is the process of
creating a prompt that is designed to
improve performance
this may involve using domain-specific
knowledge providing examples of the
desired output or using keywords that
are known to be effective for the
specific system
prompt design is a more General concept
while prompt engineering is a more
specialized concept prompt design is
essential while prompt engineering is
only necessary for systems that require
a high degree of accuracy or performance
there are three kinds of large language
models generic language models
instruction tuned and dialogue tuned
each needs prompting in a different way
generic language models predict the next
word based on the language in the
training data
this is an example of a generic language
model the next word is a token based on
the language in the training data
in this example the cat sat on the next
word should be the and you can see that
the is the most likely next word
think of this type as an autocomplete in
search
in instruction tuned the model is
trained to predict a response to the
instructions given in the input
for example summarize a text of X
generate a poem in the style of X give
me a list of keywords based on semantic
similarity for x
and in this example classify the text
into neutral negative or positive
in dialogue tuned the model is trained
to have a dialogue by the next response
dialogue tuned models are a special case
of instruction tuned where requests are
typically framed as questions to a chat
bot dialogue tuning is expected to be in
the context of a longer back and forth
conversation and typically works better
with natural question-like phrasings
Chain of Thought reasoning is the
observation that models are better at
getting the right answer when they first
output text that explains the reason for
the answer
let's look at the question Roger has
five tennis balls he buys two more cans
of tennis balls each can has three
tennis balls how many tennis balls does
he have now
this question is posed initially with no
response the model is less likely to get
the correct answer directly however by
the time the second question is asked
the output is more likely to end with
the correct answer
a model that can do everything has
practical limitations task specific
tuning can make llms more reliable
vertex AI provides task specific
Foundation models let's say you have a
use case where you need to gather
sentiments or how your customers are
feeling about your product or service
you can use the classification task
sentiment analysis task model
same provision tasks if you need to
perform occupancy analytics there is a
task specific model for your use case
tuning a model enables you to customize
the model response based on examples of
the task that you want the model to
perform
it is essentially the process of
adapting a model to a new domain or set
of custom use cases by training the
model on new data
for example we may collect training data
and tune the model specifically for the
legal or medical domain
you can also further tune the model by
fine tuning where you bring your own
data set and retrain the model by tuning
every weight in the llm this requires a
big training job and hosting your own
fine-tuned model
here's an example of a Medical
Foundation model trained on Healthcare
data the tasks include question
answering image analysis finding similar
patients and so forth
fine-tuning is expensive and not
realistic in many cases
so are there more efficient methods of
tuning
yes parameter efficient tuning methods
or petm are methods for tuning a large
language model on your own custom data
without duplicating the model
the base model itself is not altered
instead a small number of add-on layers
are tuned which can be swapped in and
out at inference time
generative AI Studio lets you quickly
explore and customize generative AI
models that you can leverage in your
applications on Google Cloud
generative AI Studio helps developers
create and deploy generative AI models
by providing a variety of tools and
resources that make it easy to get
started for example there's a library of
pre-trained models a tool for
fine-tuning models a tool for deploying
models to production and a community
forum for developers to share ideas and
collaborate
generative AI app builder lets you
create gen AI apps without having to
write any code
gen AI app builder has a drag and drop
interface that makes it easy to design
and build apps a visual editor that
makes it easy to create and edit app
content a built-in search engine that
allows users to search for information
within the app and a conversational AI
engine that allows users to interact
with the app using natural language
you can create your own chat Bots
digital assistants custom search engines
knowledge bases training applications
and more
Palm API lets you test and experiment
with Google's large language models and
gen AI tools
to make prototyping quick and more
accessible developers can integrate Palm
API with makersweet and use it to access
the API using a graphical user interface
the suite includes a number of different
tools such as a model training tool a
model deployment tool and a model
monitoring tool the model training tool
helps developers train ml models on
their data using different algorithms
the model deployment tool helps
developers deploy ml models to
production with a number of different
deployment options
and the model monitoring tool helps
developers monitor the performance of
their ml models in production using a
dashboard and a number of different
metrics
that's all for now thanks for watching
this course introduction to large
language models